and this of course is direct from isis
to the one-eyed jew
and i love it this [ __ ] other [ __ ]
the crystals of death oh look at this it
won't even [ __ ] fall off the side
look at that jesus it's like uh mixed
opium and hash and [ __ ] straight from
the big ladies ass all right that's just
the [ __ ] it came over what's happening
lisa you up in toronto yeah i had a
great weekend telling people how to do a
podcast you're like a regular [ __ ]
simon bustinger who's that some [ __ ]
superhero from the 70s it was great i
went to the underground to the night
before after steve shows and i met puff
mama who who knew you from before i did
i had a podcast that
i've never had my name on anything
before like i've gone with you to things
and it's fun
but like i started getting really
nervous after i dropped paula off the
night before i left because i had i
realized i was packing and like my name
was on it
and it was just but it was it was it
couldn't have been more fun we did dabs
i met this great guy david who works for
like the biggest poker word in canada
and he he was telling me all about it
and then the next day we had like 20
people at the podcast seminar it was
great it was and it was the coolest
thing about it was there were people
there who didn't know me from the
podcast and i had like i got like this
one guy was there he was like 80 years
old they wanted to start a podcast it
was great all right everybody that's
kick ass yeah i i love toronto man oh my
god it was i've never been to canada oh
really ever i've always heard everyone
was really nice
but it was just so much fun and the food
was great and it was just chinese up
there [ __ ] yeah man don't [ __ ] around
good weed
they ain't [ __ ] around with that i
guess birds in the [ __ ] windows man
remember when they were shooting
everything up yeah that was good because
you you go one street and it's new york
you turn another street it's [ __ ]
chicago you go in one place that's
goddamn philadelphia i mean it's [ __ ]
the greatest town to shoot in and it the
people are amazing
you know they don't i think they the
dollar uh got weaker against the
canadian dollar it used to be but not
anymore now it's like 130 i'm uh
american for every dollar canadian so
maybe more stuff will go up i remember
being up there at the the comedy club
boris yeah i understand yeah no
hollywood yeah yeah yeah comedy wood
comedy wood
it was two weeks for 1200 600 a week the
headline
you lived over the bar but then the
second week you went to the other club
and you lived in a house with his crazy
brother who was a driver for a hooker
service yeah and he would wake you up
everybody listen this one got beat up
she's bleeding from the head she'll suck
your dick for the small
it was fifty
15 canadians had to keep the door locked
it was hard
i remember being on that block and
walking down the block one day and
seeing andy garcia
the guy from [ __ ] cheers the fat guy
oh yeah george went uh oh my god john
voight all on one block they were all
staying in the same [ __ ] hotel yeah
here i am sleeping over a [ __ ] bar i
know and then down the corner he's
deliver weed to your door in those days
35 and 8.
yeah toronto's a good they have a movie
theater
10 years ago 15 years ago they had a
movie theater with couches with
waitresses really yeah 15 years ago
there's the rooms and the beer there is
so [ __ ] good you know when uh
last time i played that i was at the
downtown room and mitch hedberg was at
the uptown room and then we flipped so
we went from bathurst and stills uh down
to down way the [ __ ] down there in
downtown and
that's when mitch met his wife lynn
it was a crazy [ __ ] time man it was
like mitch and that crazy kid josh got
arrested yeah
they got arrested in toronto right
before he met lynn yeah right before he
met lynn that club was okay but then he
cut the money and right right cut the
money and it was weird i like you know
you know what i think i think that
[ __ ] uh i think he got pressure from
the russian mafia well that he had a
partner yeah they were always there and
they were like russian jews russian
chubby guy with glasses yeah
but it's funny because uh
that whole town like it was two weeks i
might settle in there that was the only
town that i broke my thing about strip
clubs yeah
oh my god so oh yeah all my [ __ ] guys
i went to this weed room the night like
the first night i got there which they
have there which is the i think the one
thing that la's kind of missing just
places you can go and smoke and hang out
and these three girls walked in that
were literally one was just wearing it
was possibly the hottest girl i've ever
seen and right down the street it was
called like the brass rail yes
you were on blow street yeah yeah you
were on blow street that's where you
were i'm telling you i used to go up
there [ __ ] and here's how i used to
do it this is the craziest story
i used to go to the improv
and at the improv was a nice irish kid
from manhattan that was going to the u
of m
u of miami he was working himself
through college and at night he'd work
at the improv
all right he had a puerto rican
girlfriend
this is how that this is how we life is
we're at the bar one day who calls me
but roger paul and he goes boris wants
you to do two weeks
i go i can't get into [ __ ] canada i
just say this right in front of you i go
you know they want me to go to toronto i
don't think i get into canada and she
goes i could sneak you into canada i do
it every day
and i go you live in miami she goes no i
don't i just come down to visit this
knucklehead
because i live in buffalo new york but
my father's retired
and he's a professional gambler and he
gambles and
whatever they gave him a pass that goes
right [ __ ] through oh so he would
drive me to ontario to the bus station
and then i would take the bus from
ontario to toronto
and i would stay the two weeks but the
beauty was on the way out
because then i give them my id and you
see them look at the id and go
like they would [ __ ] look at the
computer and then they look at me and
they go when did you come in here and i
go last week i came on the other side no
you didn't yes i did but it's too late
[ __ ] now you know what i'm saying
it's too late baby it's too late
somebody's gonna get fired so you want
to arrest me on the way out and be my
[ __ ] guest i said i saw you and your
[ __ ] partner here
and they gave me my id and they said
don't come back i came back three more
[ __ ] times within the next like year
and a half it's a good time in the same
way but once 9 11 came they locked that
road up yeah
they locked that [ __ ] yeah you can't
hardly get over what a fun city well i
miss it what a [ __ ] and now i'd love to
go to vancouver with i remember 15 years
ago when i'm telling you this is how
long ago gavin was still married to his
wife
and he lived on martel
no no no yeah martel because him and
keith without martel this has to be
2 000 so it's 15 [ __ ] years ago 99
there was a girl that used to date larry
vizzello that was the [ __ ] cutest
blonde girl you ever saw in your life
her name like her parents were hippies
her grandparents were hippies this chick
walked around l.a barefoot dirty feet
with a suntan that [ __ ] never ended
you know she grew up on the beach but
her story was she grew up she worked on
the beach of vancouver selling pot
cookies guys
gavin was still with his wife this is 99
this is 16 years ago we we we're still
not selling wheat on the [ __ ] beach
yeah they were selling weed on the beach
uh cookies she used to bring him down
and one night she sold me and gavin a
cookie for five dollars a piece
and i remember he went home and almost
died like i remember you have enough lee
can you get two more of these for uncle
joey these are great
i've never had this but that's a dud
that's a
oh it's a dud maybe that's been there
for [ __ ] two years huh
but just a conversation at a table
got this girl got this girl to call her
dad and here's the best thing i would
take the flight to buffalo the dad would
pick me up at the airport take me to his
house let me take a shower and him and
the mother would cook for me puerto
rican red beans would pork chop [ __ ]
yeah man
and then they'd go what do you want to
do and i go nothing he goes you want to
sit down and relax you want to drive up
there let's go there's a two o'clock bus
and i that was it that's how nice this
is what you man this is the people i've
met through [ __ ] comedy
like this is what you have to write in
your book like those little stories that
people that the this is blue that's
exactly what i'm doing the little
[ __ ] road stories are the ones that
still baffle me that i just remember
right now [ __ ] like this is what i just
remember just talking to you guys yeah
man
this is this uh all we need is you
drinking all my orange juice and this is
14 40. this is [ __ ] awesome man this
is just like we used to do right there
looking out the goddamn window
that's uh what was the bloody mary mix
oh man it was a texas pete's uh bloody
mary mix we bring out from houston and
it was deadly deadly it was so good so
spicy and then we'd put pickled green
beans in it and a shrimp and lots of
horses
[ __ ] yeah
and sometimes i'd fry up a whole piece
of bacon and shove that [ __ ] in
there that's how you do it lee
put the jew in your back pocket i'm
gonna bring you back to life
that's what we did we get [ __ ] up on
that i was having a talk of ralphie last
week and i said you know what ralphie
sometimes i just want to blink my eyes
and go back to 1440. yeah because those
nights with no money
was some of the best the night you
burned your head the scout oh my god he
was there was my [ __ ] hand it was a
chinese light he was yelling at jody and
his head was perfectly under the chinese
light and i was about to say something
but you know me i'm gonna come here and
go let him burn his [ __ ] sky
goes ah
and me and jody just busted out
i've been getting coked up with jody and
drinking the vodka and filling it back
up with water i know i know
so funny oh my god oh man how about the
time you were over at uh gavin's and you
had the bolivian flu and his little
[ __ ] male [ __ ] pug dog
yeah bread up the back of the [ __ ]
couch went to coco who's got his eyes
closed sleeping upright
trying to [ __ ] i mean just wreaking a
[ __ ] and [ __ ] yay and and he had
[ __ ] on his [ __ ] shirt and that
[ __ ] cock's like a dog pissed on your
head that was the [ __ ] funniest [ __ ]
i've ever seen there's a lot of [ __ ]
coke in that building ah good times a
lot of [ __ ] coke was done in that
building because i always stayed out of
that no no you never did none of that
[ __ ] it was just it was around you i
used to go to your house drink bloody
mary's with you yeah and be doing little
tiny bumps in the bathroom [ __ ] hey
[ __ ] up in that little apartment till
four in the morning how much did you
know ralphie oh he knew all of it come
on it's coco you know you know what's
fun though is when he comes in with the
rare story all right i started doing
blue with this chick turns out it wasn't
blue it was hair on we [ __ ] all night
it was crazy i loved it it was
tremendous all right i think that was 2
000 okay that was a great one but that's
the only time he ever did putting dude
thanksgiving was [ __ ] epic that
thanksgiving
with marilyn
yeah
yes oh my god [ __ ] you did it
he he ate an ounce of mushrooms lee an
ounce not a [ __ ] eighth a goddamn
ounce i was [ __ ] up with you i kept
you those [ __ ] things he ate like a
pig he [ __ ] smoked the best reefer
that's when you used to have a jar on
the top yeah big ass chocolate pound jar
on the paper
let's do this
and and let me tell you what that i've
never seen anybody been able to do that
many drugs and stand coco not only stood
he went down to the [ __ ] or got a big
old [ __ ] rock and a ball all right
did that [ __ ] and and from what i heard
blew the [ __ ] comedy store away i
hadn't done the coke yet i got the coke
and took it home
i did the mushrooms and went to the
store and was [ __ ] lit and nobody
showed up
so like you got to go up next
i was [ __ ] lit on these mushrooms and
i went up there and i just looked
straight ahead and the lights were
turning purple and the original room
like that's all i kept seeing was purple
you know right
but i heard you got a standing ovation
oh my god people were calling me
19 people it was like 19 people yeah and
you stood them that's way more
impressive than 500 people
if you're a comic and you're hearing
this you understand to get a standing
ovation from 19 [ __ ] people is more
amazing than getting it for 25 000
people that's easy anybody can [ __ ]
do that all right these people were
there on thanksgiving night and [ __ ]
diaz blew them away [ __ ] tremendous
uh those you know you you you think
about what a night that was marilyn was
all [ __ ] up we had a blast we all ate
it was great time i was telling my wife
today that it's
you know we had our friend that called
today and said that somebody died and
i'm like you know i was eating with my
wife at the time ago you know what
i don't want to seem like what's that
word when people are you're not whatever
i'm grateful okay empathetic when you're
not empathetic but life moves on if i
drank with you at a bar 20 years ago and
you die i'm very sad but what do you
want me to do stop my world and you know
and it's just uh
i think about maryland a lot and it
pisses me off how people talk [ __ ]
but i was telling my wife today i go you
know i see this girl all the time that
was marilyn's friend i see her all the
time now at the store
and all the times i've seen yeah she
comes over and says hello but she never
pulls me inside and says do you still
think about maryland i think about
maryland all the time i buy the candle
from maryland on mondays
with a candle for merrell i see him he's
a peach man i changed the waterfall and
it's weird
how for years she used to call me and
[ __ ] and one day i told her i said do
me a favor man stop [ __ ] bitching
go out there and
rock the world you know you're always
bitching about what you're not getting
it's not about what you're not getting
this focus on what you're getting if
mitzi's giving you three spots you're
getting three more spots and a lot of
other [ __ ] people yeah no [ __ ] so she
would she was so powerful one of the
most powerful women comics i've ever
seen she would go on stage late night
and some nights [ __ ] blow that
with that filipino dick she used to like
to suck filipino
it was like a little sausage she's
rolling around her mouth
that people you see what big guys would
say i live 300 pounds today well lift me
[ __ ] you know just
dumb [ __ ] that would just make you laugh
late night she's so funny
so funny what's up with you lisa yeah
you bad [ __ ] you're going to the
double tomorrow that's it they're making
you do kettlebells and you just i can't
do doubles yeah you missed last week he
called me tonight he's like did he come
last year yeah
yeah so he goes yeah he's got to do it
double you've lost a lot of weight since
i saw him
almost a hundred battles jiu-jitsu he's
been stuck at 98 because him and the
wife of [ __ ] savage hey it's not
though it's not me and the wife it's me
and the [ __ ] 200 300 milligrams oh
please
please don't [ __ ] bull what'd you go
to the wives and eat last night
oh moley yeah first time ever yeah i
know oh wow i know so many people go on
a mole diet but
i know so many [ __ ] that
include mole in their diet she didn't
put chocolate in it no you don't need
chocolate and [ __ ] moles yes you do
that's the half of isn't that what
rolling in no that's just one part of
mexico
right they don't her uh her mom and her
don't like chocolate in it so we just
had that it's just chicken what's in the
sauce i have no idea it's [ __ ]
amazing it's amazing it's a little bit
of jesus but yeah but it wasn't spicy
i'm getting used to spicy you know it's
not spicy at all
depending on i didn't but now i do it's
just flavorful that's what you know all
these white people are afraid of mexican
spice if you watch mexican spicy food
they just put a little bit of salsa like
a little bit of do you dumb white people
are used to [ __ ] ketchup on their
goddamn tacos they're [ __ ] i was in
washington and my [ __ ] buddy goes
let's go to taco time okay it's a chain
a [ __ ] chain up there and the [ __ ]
lady said do you want mild salsa or
ketchup on your tacos and i [ __ ]
laughed i go bro if you eat that i'm
gonna [ __ ] fire you because i can't
stand to look at your face and we just
left it there we paid for it and left it
[ __ ] anybody
ain't no taco cabana you [ __ ] no man
some potato tacos for breakfast
they don't know man they don't know we
used to [ __ ] it up what's been going on
talk to me man i uh this summer was a
little crazy for me you know my ptsd i
thought was being handled with uh
antidepressants but it's not it wasn't
and now it is and now it's
antidepressants and mood stabilizers and
men i feel [ __ ] like i haven't felt
in five years bro i don't hurt i [ __ ]
i am up at seven throwing sidekicks for
jesus i'm [ __ ] the wife real good i'm
putting her legs up i'm hugging my
babies i'm playing with my babies more
i'm more focused and it's like you know
man you were absolutely right i didn't
like the [ __ ] truth being told to me
but man it was the goddamn truth coco
when you broke it down hey pal you've
been slipping a little bit you were
[ __ ] right you were goddamn right and
it's and i didn't know how bad it was
until i [ __ ] went to the goddamn
doctor and describing all my [ __ ] and he
goes you're under medicated for your
ptsd you are way the [ __ ] under a
medicated and now man i feel like i
haven't felt in years man like the whole
world isn't closing in on me like
[ __ ] like la's not bothering me as
much traffic doesn't bother me [ __ ]
nothing bothers me no more man i am
[ __ ] great with life it is fantastic
to not be pissed off except for when
deadly needed you know what i mean it's
nice it's hard nice it's joey's one of
the worst people to get those truth
bombs because we you like you in the
back of your head you know he's right
and that's the [ __ ] worst and he's
not right about it like i'm not saying
you're right about everything because no
one's right about everything
but when you like when you've had a
couple we've had a couple of those talks
and during it you like you hate them it
it and it's just brutal you hate i think
it's just anybody who you hate like when
can like is it so
like the most
nine out of ten men
are mad at their dads
because they confront us they're our
mirror but they're not doing that you
hate
you hate the people
growing up i hated my stepdad because
he would
break my [ __ ]
he would break whatever move i made he
was two steps ahead of me
you you always don't like the people i
grew up around people that in all those
years i was [ __ ] up
at the end of the night when i was
coming down off the coast they said
listen we had a great time and stuff i
got to talk to you
somebody came and talked to me they know
that this guy you robbed his house i
don't mean to bring this up but i didn't
want to ruin your night last night sleep
on the couch
get up in the morning and we gotta
handle this
and they're not telling me what to do
they're not asking me what to do
they're kind of hinting to me
what the right thing to do and i get
pissed
one of the worst conversations i ever
had was with matt wood and when he came
up to me at the comedy works and he goes
why do you come here
ralphie 95. yeah i'm ready to kill my
ex-wife i'm living in a basement
i have no food in the refrigerator i'm
sustaining just to do blow
pay my rent and pay child support
i'm lifting weights i'm doing the right
thing but i'm gonna [ __ ] roll every
night
and i would cancel all the time the open
mic and this guy came up to me and he
goes can i talk to you for a second
he's like hey man why do you come down
here why do you waste your time in that
time because let me be as honest i can
with you because just being you you're
the funniest out of all these open
micros god forbid you wrote a joke and
god forbid you showed up
look at your t-shirt you got a white
t-shirt on
you got a white t-shirt on dog my hands
were [ __ ] clenching to punch this guy
in the mouth
and he goes i'm not saying nothing bad
about you you're funnier than these guys
just being you and you're throwing it
away
i know you're doing blow i know you
don't do it here but i know you're doing
and this guy just read me the writer i
walked to the bus in denver ralphie and
walked back to beat him up and when i
went back god let him know to get the
[ __ ] out of there he got out of there
you know where i seen the guy again
bumped into the guy again
in 98 at the brave bull
and wow in her hamburger and i followed
the guy that used to come out with the
hat and go hi
my like my wife and i like my tits with
brown coffee the guy was like a
detective yeah dwight something in the
80s yeah dwight slate no no the white
slate the guys from portland yeah
friends with hicks this is a different
guy dwight something and i followed him
and ripped the room apart and he was
back there with brian dunkleman oh
they had just moved to l.a together man
and he came to me those basil
i pulled him aside i go matt wood and he
hugged me and he goes
that was he goes i'm really proud of you
you know why
because of that talk you had with me and
he took me outside he goes
i was never more scared in my life but
you had to hear it he goes me todd and a
bunch of comics talked about it and todd
didn't have the balls to say something
to you because i thought you were going
to punch me in the face i go it changed
my life
it changed who i am today i'm in l.a
because of the [ __ ] words you said
yeah as much as i hated them that night
you know
you are
in my eyes when i talk about headliners
of this decade you're the top guys i
learned from
you have no time to slip and the
godfather there's a line that every time
i hear it i want to punch myself in the
face and it's the [ __ ] worst line you
could ever say
but where i come from it's true
women and children can slip
men don't slip
that's it yeah
women and children can make a mistake
men can't make mistakes we we don't have
i'm fear i don't have time to make a
mistake anymore
i do not have time to
to to
do anything we've got handed the keys to
the castle ralphie yeah
you and i have been handed the keys to
the castle without a doubt i haven't had
a job
in 20 [ __ ] years
i've never had an answer to somebody
after i went to prison i didn't like a
man kicking my bed and telling me to
wake up right i haven't had an answer to
somebody well i haven't had to answer
somebody since i was 15
but for a job to make a living
and somehow it came together even when
you were in your [ __ ] apartment it
always came together as long as you were
out every night right you were writing
every night you [ __ ] hustle right
every day work every night
is it scary
when you see like how close it is like
so i just did that that seminar
and now i'm trying to start doing more
more of them
and i wasn't even really scared before
the first but now that i'm like oh i
could i could see i really enjoyed doing
it
and now that i can see
not that it's going to be easy but i i
can see that but it's possible like
after you guys do shows you see that as
possible and you know that there's a ton
of work to put in like at least for me
it got scarier i'll tell you what your
market needs right now and this guy's a
genius of getting the business for you
but i think right now what you're doing
[ __ ] these little comedians i think
they're gonna start a podcast they're
gonna start a podcast they know how to
do it okay i think you're
people is that computer people yeah tech
people people who really
are uncomfortable they don't know this
world and they want to learn it from a
to z comics know this world
they have friends that are doing this
right now every comic is doing this
right now okay it's uh it's just it's
you're going you're going after pennies
when you go after dollars
it's just gonna take you a little work
but when you strike one of those
companies
you're gonna hit oh you can go after
companies okay go after [ __ ] a t and
t and go how come at t there's another
podcast every week yeah that's crazy
talking about their services and what's
going on with phones and technology and
like answering people and answering
that's your next move that's who's at
home going right now there's a board
meeting going we're losing 22
because we're not computer uh we're not
savvy savvy yeah what is going on tell
us about that look at [ __ ] amazon
amazon today is getting slammed by
[ __ ] [ __ ] work conditions for people
i mean they're keeping people working in
[ __ ] warehouses over 110 degrees with
no breaks they time everything they need
some [ __ ] counter that [ __ ] i mean i
don't want to buy amazon now i mean but
if if they would have a podcast they
could explain it and tell me hey the air
conditioning broke you know maybe i
don't know the full context maybe the
full context is not being reported you
know those [ __ ] news agencies is
always a [ __ ] by the way i'd like to
hear the other guys [ __ ] side of this
[ __ ] all right and that's exactly what
they need lee i mean you can [ __ ]
kill that [ __ ] dude and you know who
told me this once i remember houston was
the hardest comedy thing
of all yeah
and in the late 90s it was really
booming and one day i went to latino
night and dane cook was there
and i go up today and i go dan how was
houston he goes man
that's a great club but he goes you know
what
it was too many shows for the money i
got to figure out how to just do one big
show there
five years later he was doing
thieversley yeah my point is that yeah
you could go to gold
there's expenses and you know how
expensive is being out there ralphie
it's [ __ ] the biggest expenses it's
it's it's so there's a lot of expenses
for the price you were charging i mean
your thing is a workshop right it's nine
the [ __ ] five type deal for these
people like your thing is a workshop
your thing isn't just one hour your
thing is a [ __ ] workshop yeah we did
like almost two hours and it wasn't
enough time no your thing is a workshop
there's two parts to yours they gotta go
eat lunch and come back and have
questions you think i should just do
like a whole like rent a room at a hotel
that's what i've been thinking about
like [ __ ] yeah yeah build it and get
it
and do it off days you can you can save
a lot of money if you do it off days bro
and uh you know if you can and and
book into it that you can adjust the
size of the room
all right so if you have a big turnout
then they can open it up like the
bananas it's a small boom like banana
jerseys heights you know you ever see
and
bananas
and
those commercials for real estate people
that come to your town and teach you how
to make a million dollars yeah but
that's a scam i don't want to scam and
you're not scamming nobody i'm just
saying it's the same type of thing at
least will be in your area and then what
you could do is maybe do a big one and
then do a comedy club so you get two
bangers for a buck okay i bet i bet
zany's in nashville would do it bro yeah
zany's in there there's a ton of comics
there that need to be podcasting and if
you had there i mean you could do they
put it out to all the comedy clubs in
the southeast and all these comics to
come there's [ __ ] 40 guys in memphis
there's [ __ ] [ __ ] ton in louisville
lexington [ __ ] knoxville chattanooga
atlanta birmingham man all of those guys
will come up i'd love to do them
everywhere but and that was the one
thing that i was surprised by like the
crowd that came out to toronto
wasn't a lot of comics there were a
couple there but it was mostly other
people you need right now there's
businesses yeah that really need your
services
you have to find a way to reach them and
go listen you know how long you've been
plumbing 32 years not for nothing if
you're making a living doing it you know
a thing or two right get somebody else
on there even if it's for a half hour
the plumbing show who gives a [ __ ] today
it didn't [ __ ] home improvement i
don't remember for years oh yeah man you
would teach how to tear up a floor
what's the difference doing it on a
[ __ ] podcast no there is no
difference what's the difference people
want to hear that i'll hear it on the
way to work and a lot of those guys are
[ __ ] funny as [ __ ] yeah
naturally they just need to co-host
somebody in between yeah
somebody's got to steer them there's got
to be a program also lee that you can
push these people on to go one two three
abc and do what you did call them and go
hey i'm referring these people i did
that you know i know you did that but
you have to do it more with more
companies yeah now the next one is the
people they contacted downloaded because
you're leaving so they don't know how to
[ __ ] download this there's got to be
a company to teach them how to do that
now you got to go to them and go oh yo
i'm going to send you 18 [ __ ] people
a dollar a piece every week whatever i'm
just saying right
you're sitting on the gold mine late
that's just you have to point it at the
right direction yeah you have a brother
bullet just come to nashville okay i'll
set it up i'll set it up i'll get you a
night okay i know everybody [ __ ] run
out there and support you nashville
always supports us podcasts or comics
okay that'd be great and dude and not
only that you don't even have to get a
hotel you can stay at my house my house
is uh like eight blocks away from the
club
and it's empty it's a big [ __ ] house
food freezer [ __ ] yeah chili there's
[ __ ] everything i got everything in
there ready to go i'd love to yeah man
lee be my pleasure and i even got my
buddy aaron who'll pick you up from the
hote i mean from the airport my car you
can drive my car oh my god
people talk to me all the time about
starting something yeah especially when
they go on the road that they do this i
had a dentist talk to me about it i had
a shoe guy but i [ __ ] lost a car okay
oh yeah in boston yeah the boston i had
a people are interested in this they
just don't know where to start it's like
uh what's his name said in the sopranos
everybody wants a cooler they just don't
know where to buy one you know i'm
saying yeah right well that's that's
like that's the issue i found when i was
building it it's just if you google it
there's 8 000 people telling you 20 000
different ways to build a podcast so
like that's what i said at the beginning
like this is just the way i did listen
but here's the [ __ ] thing okay this
is me this is [ __ ] me okay yes i
bought the [ __ ] judy brown workbook
right and i read about comedy like every
other comedy did but i learned from
watching ralphie man i learned from
watching bill burr and greg geraldo and
joe rogan and ari and duncan you learn
different things
okay
right now you know i saw that ad for the
people on tv hi we could uh up your
marketing and do this and this and this
that's great but i'll tell you what you
got you got some kid that went to school
for marketing there between that kid and
you is you're living it you've seen it
you've seen how our numbers went up what
we did what works and what different
works in some markets how many times
have you called me and said wow we had
this guy who's a celebrity and he's got
no hits and this guy's a plumber and
he's got 2 000 [ __ ] hits i wonder
what the [ __ ] happened we learned not to
release a podcast on a friday right but
it's a dead [ __ ] thing we learned not
to edit a [ __ ] podcast these are the
things we learned by doing we used to do
a podcast we used to edit it we stopped
editing it the numbers went through the
[ __ ] roof right you know and they
hear you say [ __ ] and yam and [ __ ]
chinese
[ __ ] they
yeah so this is what you have to tell
the people that they're gonna sit there
and look at you if i had any type of
business today flooring [ __ ] tiles
if i wasn't a snappy guy i'd have
somebody in there but i'd have them
pushing the envelope because i want
people to say what the [ __ ] is ralphie
mae flooring talking about fingers up an
[ __ ] this could not continue i'm like
i'm a
christian these are the people that push
you more these are the people are going
to go you own that company
and that's what you're trying to do
that's what you're trying to do online
that is the social whatever you could go
on facebook and dick around and show
people what you had for lunch who gives
a [ __ ]
you know who gives a [ __ ] unless you're
reading uh especially because people
follow so many people you really have to
stick out you really yeah man and
especially if you have a business if you
say i mean you'll get a lot of hits if
you like took what you have for lunch
and it's like giner you know if it's a
nice [ __ ] meat all right that'll get a
lot of hits
but that's only it man if you're taking
a picture of your [ __ ] sandwich go
[ __ ] yourself why don't you tape your
workouts i like going to v-max for the
kettlebells but when they take my
workers it drives me crazy i do it for
them because i like them but i don't do
it for me to why i [ __ ] hate that
[ __ ] why i hate that [ __ ] for me to go
to the gym and periscope myself listen i
go on the periscope and i do what i do
best and that smoked reefer for five
minutes
i don't want to talk to nobody after
five minutes right or wrong if you're
smoking good weed you smoke the joint
you had your soda you had your donut is
there anything else i could do for you
no all right see you later bye
get pasadena [ __ ] out of here putting
the stereo on i'm getting [ __ ] that's
that's right man i'm [ __ ] youtuber
music i wanna sit here smoke dope and
we'll look at you scratch your feet yeah
right go to your own house and scratch
your feet let me sit here and meditate
on this [ __ ] hash i just smoked i'm
hearing [ __ ] sirens and [ __ ]
that's the point that's the [ __ ]
point of this whole thing is to get away
and people want to [ __ ] crowd you i
love getting high but i love getting
high
i don't trust it anymore my favorite
thing in life is to put get high and put
[ __ ] uh speakers on and just go for a
[ __ ] walk in the sun you can't do it
yeah somebody's gonna come up behind you
and shoot you in the head or you don't
hear explosions or [ __ ] you know isis
is running through the park now you are
listening to [ __ ] princess man
[ __ ] speaking of isis i was down in
irvine
holy [ __ ]
that is the most arabs i've seen since
[ __ ] kuwait
all right
holy [ __ ] dude these [ __ ] retards
they throw their goddamn carpets out in
front of the [ __ ] fountain it looks
like valet parking for magic carpets
it's arabian nights why are you
tormenting
out there that's why because those
[ __ ] they're very combustible that's
why
and and i've gotten shot at by those
[ __ ]
people over there
not the
looking blow up be like a [ __ ]
man
i'll throw a ham sandwich at them
they'll kill themselves i'll solve this
[ __ ] problem
i had [ __ ] success
with people from those communities i
don't know why and when i was young you
know i had my i like i like some of them
you know who i really dig and it's
[ __ ] crazy iranians i [ __ ] like
iranians more than i do the arabs all
right i'm [ __ ] way more i love
iranians i love the armenians oh i like
the armenians too they're [ __ ] crazy
and it's like hey comb your shoulder bro
like at this point in my life everybody
yeah i got you yeah right listen i hate
russians i'll tell you that i don't like
russians why don't you
keep up crashing people up they're gonna
drop a
i hate grenade russian russians i've
hated since uh russian since goddamn 84.
why are you they killed swayze and red
dawn they can suck my dick and you know
what they killed apollo creed too [ __ ]
don't forget both of them
hey
russians they put baby in the corner
[ __ ] them [ __ ] i hate those
[ __ ] people eat a dick
they got nice [ __ ] wheat stores they
don't bother nobody they always give you
an extra gram they know what's going on
yeah the restaurants here they're the
ones who are seeking the great american
dream and taking over white people and
punching them in the face i'm talking
about the [ __ ] russian russians
okay they're in russia okay i mean
police probably [ __ ] russian jews i
am yeah yeah he's ashkenazi like a nick
man i love that guy all right but it's
it that's what it is that's what it is
it leads down okay
like a nickname yeah right for real
because look at you lee you ain't
wearing no sweater in the [ __ ] summer
okay you ain't smoking [ __ ] crazy
cigarettes you don't smell like smoked
fish all right those jews always smell
like [ __ ] fish those [ __ ] crazy
russian jews over there in west
hollywood that's all they got that's all
they got bro they are fairfax oh man i
wish they were on fairfax they're on
sunset that's a big place that club by
that uh urban ramen place that used to
be that i mean it's been like a thousand
places it was right across some green
tea house where we used to go remember
we used to go over there for [ __ ]
it's right across that's a big russian
hangout dude they're all russian
gangsters all right
one of their girls hit one of our cars
and they came out and said it was our
fault and the car was parked and nobody
was in the [ __ ] car and they started
to [ __ ] saying something and you know
me coco i carry a pistol a lot a lot
okay i've got a i've got a class three
weapons license okay and i've got
distinction from the fbi all right i can
carry the [ __ ] thing anywhere okay i
can fly with it all right and i'll just
[ __ ] pull my gun i just pulled the
gun and the guys backed the [ __ ] off and
we got to exchange information and
[ __ ] with no drama all right but they
were [ __ ] surrounding my wife what
the [ __ ] am i supposed to do
i got hit by a russian lady in a parking
lot up here and she she refused to but
it was her yeah she was like 90 years
old so i felt really bad but she just
she was like no that wasn't me and her
car was filled with dents
just
oh my god i got head too i got hit by a
russians me too she paid the stanley
[ __ ] you pay me you gotta pay me i got
that one insurance i don't know who the
[ __ ] they are [ __ ] you pay me and see
you later bye
it's crazy though i used to you know
i always crack jokes and like i say on
stage i'm not really a racist at all i'm
not a you know whatever but i say racist
remarks for a laugh for myself
at least to keep me the [ __ ]
sensitive because in the back of my mind
i know they're saying [ __ ] about specs
oh man if i'm not around i know people
are talking about mexicans and i'm not
even [ __ ] mexican i hear them i hear
people talking about mexican their real
views
and i giggle and i don't make a joke but
i [ __ ] know now at least i know how
you feel
you know it doesn't bother me i'm not
look listen i've never felt
i felt insecure
growing up to like being second like
being third tier because i was cuban
but i never
got offended when people said [ __ ] to me
growing up dude i was white
trash was [ __ ] white trash and now
i'm fat white trash
you know what are you gonna do what the
[ __ ] you right exactly [ __ ] it i learned
early on if they say that type of [ __ ]
just giggle and i always do ah they're
just i never had a beef with it one time
i had a beef with it and i had it i was
mad anyway so he just gave me an excuse
what's up lee look at you you're back in
coma [ __ ] hell yeah mama waiting for
you tonight yep oh [ __ ] she's there what
you making over there what's she making
for dinner i don't know what for dinner
yeah i guess what do you think what do
you think is what what do you bank on
probably like a sandwich i don't know
like a turkey sandwich
oh yeah that's what she's making for
dinner i don't know
what's your life turkey sandwich i don't
know it's gonna be like 11 o'clock at
night you know lee you gotta you gotta
come to my house for a turkey sandwich i
get jewish rye all right and i put uh
put a little uh russian and dressing on
there i know i hate the russians so it's
ironic that i like the dressing all
right and then and then good ass turkey
right there a little sauerkraut make a
reuben right there
and cheese what you'd love it
you'd love it
you'd love it
maybe you are the shittiest jew of all
time you know that all the all the time
yeah he's so removed from the rules of
yeah i mean
your guideline for what i've eaten right
and the rules of being from boston he's
he fell did you even get bar mitzvahed
yeah okay my portion was noah your what
name is noah no no you have a portion
like every week it's a different story
and my story was known your story yeah
he read part of the scroll
he found that mexican chicken no he's
the one that had the art
yeah man
no put all the animals in two by two
it's no it's just i didn't
i had my
mic right saying some of that for us i
know you still remember it i don't
remember don't you [ __ ] me
especially those jews dwell that [ __ ]
into you for six [ __ ] years i know
it's terrible
i don't like what like the like noah or
just just any of that of it come on sing
it come on let's see
i think that's like one over bread i'm
not sure yeah that's all
wow yeah i need this [ __ ] in my life
sure why not you got to know right now
what if you're ever in israel you gotta
bless some bread no [ __ ] man hey and you
know what [ __ ] number one in israel
right now in georgia what's happening
now as [ __ ] yeah jesus just went crazy
if i would go if i got it right [ __ ]
them up right man i i like i like israel
i like the way they [ __ ] roll
i do yeah it's getting scarier like okay
i went over there and it was fine but
now you see like
i used to be all pro-israel but now you
gotta look at it kind of objectively and
realize they're both kind of [ __ ] up
everybody's [ __ ] up man
just go to haifa and everything is
really nice yeah everything's chill and
hyphen man what i was going to say to
you was there's no guidelines but
i always thought people from the east
coast ate a little differently at least
growing up i did about two years ago my
best friend in jersey his son came out
here
his no his sister's son came out here
who i knew since he was a little kid
and we were talking and when somebody
comes out and they're [ __ ] 17 they go
to the navy
i said do you want to go out to dinner
where do you want to go and he's like
i don't care you could take me to the
subway
and i said you're from north virginia
you're from the projects in north bergen
and
subway
he goes that's all i eat the subway or
my grandma's spaghetti
i go so that's all you ate growing up
yes joan didn't take you to picca lisa
no joan didn't take it uh what's that
champion
dragon inn
you give one of them [ __ ] tiki drinks
so i didn't know that have you been
there lee yeah so good man then [ __ ]
egg rolls [ __ ] spare ribs are really
good oh man the spare ribs counting the
[ __ ] days but it's so weird i i
thought people ate fried rice no pizza
that's what it was i just thought i ate
differently but you know when i went to
new york city
10 years ago and i saw
the thing that red man likes
olive garden this is the show oh that's
disgusting 48th street in the middle of
times square times square i knew it was
over i knew that there was a lack of
everything whoever rented that building
should be [ __ ] shot and hung
two times in the head but that's the way
i was in long island in an elevator and
i saw a kid coming up with domino's
pizza
and i almost died one time i was stuck
in long island overnight i just went to
the hotel it was a terrible hotel and i
went to the guy can i get a menu and he
gave me a chinese manual i just ordered
because i was hungry lee the best
[ __ ] food i had in years at this
little because long island has two
airports they have that big airport
which is kennedy yeah jfk and then they
have that little one out there the
southwest flies into there a lot of
people don't know about that airport yep
but bro that's a wall it's slip right
it's iceland that's a long flight
from [ __ ] i took that flight on a
cheap run
on some howard stern reunion show in the
theater and craig gas was supposed to go
on howard stern and howard stern hung up
on him
so we only sold 80 tickets
and i got a big song and dance at the
end of the [ __ ] show it was horrible
oh about about how we didn't sell enough
we can't pay you yeah man there's always
those [ __ ] usually it's a black
guy all right
oh my god there was an [ __ ] named
vance bradford that still owes me for a
gig at texas a m okay from [ __ ] 94
jack
yeah yeah that's the manager and he
still owes me 500 for that he's a
[ __ ] dick all right and you know i'm
rich i don't even 500 is dinner with us
you're right you remember all those
[ __ ] but i remember the guys that
[ __ ]
[ __ ] me when i needed it judy brown 25
bucks
for an mc spot in vail colorado no hotel
i had the car from uh
lakewood chrysler plymouth and on that
night it was so cold i had to sleep in
my car when i started the fan belt
[ __ ] snapped and i had to get i just
left the car there and quit the job
i never called up i never went and got
my last check there was no use i just
left the car there wow i called him he
said the fan belt broke i don't know
what to tell you i'm not coming back
yeah what happened i just i'm like this
was a sign from god
yeah for 25 bucks the [ __ ] car blew
up
that was not bro i had a ton of jobs i
would just take the job to get the car
my god man tell them about gas
stationing okay in new jersey no listen
to this
when i went back to colorado in 93
i lived in colorado from october i was
in my 23 i went back to i lived with my
cousin al coelo
in arvada for about three months
and basically all he did was get me
advances to go to places to get a job
yeah so i would walk into your
dealership with a suit on and go i'm
going to run your [ __ ] latino
division
first i went to douglas toyota who had
the strongest latino division they had
alcohol on this mexican dude they put
the mexican dude on television and said
we'll [ __ ] finance you we speak
spanish
[ __ ] douglas toyota went from selling
300 cars a month to 450. wow 150 cars a
month to the mexican community two sales
[ __ ] yeah man selling 150 cars two
mexicans
and another mexican my cousin and this
mexican al coelho bought a home he was
stuck yeah i mean they were killing and
then the word got out
so al hired me and i went over there i
went over there with no money in my
pocket and how got me i think a 1500 up
front
a car to take home every night with a
license plate with no drama and i could
work my own hours so if i had a gig i
could leave at 8 o'clock
and i think for 90 days dawg i made
seven to eight grand a month but i was
there you gotta be there yeah and it's a
liner closure store what that means is
how you doing ralphie may what's
happening everything beautiful yeah
what's cracking i'm looking for a truck
okay let me show you this truck you like
it you want to drive it yeah we come
back can i get you the numbers let's go
what do you do i came in here with a
range rover come on let's do the numbers
i sit you down then i bring the [ __ ]
flying jew in there a [ __ ] i
don't give a [ __ ] about nothing this guy
sold his mother a car for a thousand
over retail and he comes in and works
roughly man and guess what i that's it i
never see ralphie may again i sell that
car you get a percentage from the
dealership to close the deal guess what
i do
i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] i go right back out
there and get another custom and in
those days that blot had so many
customers that i would just qualify
right there what's happening ralph you
may know what's cracking what are you
looking for a truck let me ask you
something
if we make a deal today you're gonna buy
today well i don't know listen listen
don't hit me with that i don't know [ __ ]
either run or off you're gonna buy a
truck cause i'll [ __ ] go in there and
fight you like a [ __ ] i'll get
that truck down to bare bones today let
me see a thousand in your pocket and
they go let's do it and i had this
[ __ ] on i drive him come back
push him to a close that's line of
clothes so you throw eight [ __ ]
to the grave
six of them are gonna buy
two of them are gonna be bad credit so i
sold four cars for the [ __ ] day
it's just numbers you just got to talk
to them you got to grab people in those
days you had to hide behind cars and
[ __ ] and spook people you think i'm
[ __ ]
you think i'm kidding you though you got
to stand by the door and put your hand
on the car were you heavy then or no no
i was in shape you had to drive in and
put your hand on the door
and walk them to a parking spot and
greet them and then take them and
[ __ ] jam them in the ass and then
when they [ __ ] got pissed off at me i
said [ __ ] you and i just started harming
myself going to different dealerships
and going let me talk to the owner
listen
how many [ __ ] specs you selling i'm
on three well we're gonna kick that up
to [ __ ] 44. how this is what we're
going to do you're going to do ads on
the radio i'm going to do them in
spanish and that's all i did for a year
i'd work there for a month i'd get an
advance like five grand pay the
attorneys from the child support all
that [ __ ] i owed and i just keep moving
ralphy man it was amazing how many
people i put together at the end i
finally put together a used car lot
one of those [ __ ] 60 cars in the lot
they finally
i got one of those jobs and that job
wasn't bad they let me work my hours
until one night the engine blew up
how did the engine blow up dawg listen
in those days with my luck i was
watching swat the other night the guy
goes to the restaurant he kills his
uncle he gets in a car he gets pulled
over for a [ __ ] a busted taillight
right that's the kind of luck you have
when you live in those circles
you understand me so in in those days
anything i touch
blew up
blew up oh didn't i blow up and mainly
i was just wondering if you're going to
talk about that that's the greatest
story of all time
oh my god
she was a dumb bride who was all in love
with joshua all right and and and
and to get closer to josh this big ass
girl she she she could only get like 500
for a piece of [ __ ] car she was getting
she got a new car and so she just gave
it to coco no she gave it to josh oh she
gave it to josh and josh gave it to coco
okay so so i think we're over like a
like a bag of weed okay he got a car all
right so coco lost he he was dating the
tooth and he [ __ ] got another stop
better but tell him the whole story oh
i'm going to the car had air
conditioning it had power windows it was
a real nissan cruise but the brakes were
a little low but what happened was she
gave me the car with only a month and a
half on the tags
so i used to sleep in this [ __ ]
at night yeah i would snort coke and go
in that car open the sunroof i'd put a
blanket over me i'd jerk off into a sock
and roll over and listen to air
conditioner then i wake raffi up at nine
and go eat his food yeah
so they once the place is fired always
shout out to the shower two times a day
all right
two or three times a day at the comedy
store would shower at nine when it
opened and then i go back about
7 30 before anybody would go down there
because i didn't want jeff to catch me
naked in the past
that [ __ ] gave me a shot
piano dick
that's a d minor
that is crazy so they kept giving once
the tags expired there were these black
chicks
with the donut haircut the donut dude
yeah with a gold tooth i'll never forget
that woman and what she would do is she
would look for that car i used to watch
her yeah and she would just pull over
and give her the ticket because that's
what they do to expire taxes she would
just pull off she recognized the car
yeah that car had so many [ __ ]
tickets but there was more storage dude
no you had you had red zone tickets oh
it was done
tickets okay it was like ten thousand
dollars why didn't you just park in a
better place because they still fired me
that was helped by the place he's
parking like compadre and they [ __ ]
it's still fine how much is it to
register a car i couldn't register it
because she had the title she never gave
josh the title oh [ __ ] oh no you
have no idea oh but i took that card dog
i drove that car with no brakes
for about two or three months no brakes
no insurance no registration wait still
no nothing lately
let me tell you man okay you knew coco
was coming because you heard the squeak
of the [ __ ] other [ __ ]
breaks so it wasn't loud what happened
crazy they would just go
and smoke would come out of their tires
and i go all the way every day to
redondo beach and back because at that
time i was living in redondo beach and
i'd do 60 with that dog you have no
[ __ ] idea was i remember how do you
do sex in the car with no brains listen
to me dawg i remember
they used to do a contest
in redondo beach on thursday nights and
the king of the contest was pablo
francisco
and when he would i would look at the
schedule when he was out of town i'd go
down there on thursdays
with [ __ ] enough money to get me down
there in that calling
it was a hundred bucks it was a hundred
bucks 50 for second place or a pizza for
third place yeah and in the first place
got free food and no no i just wanted
100 because i had to come back no you
got both no i didn't even need to i
didn't even eat
plenty of time because you [ __ ] eat
it at my house
thursday listen to me
in those days
when you put a lot of dough in my pocket
yeah there was no time for food i shot
to get the blow first then we ate
just to make sure the cocaine was dead
cocaine had to get if i just made a
hundred dollars trust me
there's no food on my mind no i could be
a [ __ ] one of those africans that's
skinny with his rib cage with flies all
over him and i'm still getting in my car
and going to [ __ ] pancho's house and
getting my grandma blow whatever's left
over from the grandma blow we're putting
10 in the gas tank
we're getting five for cigarettes and
whatever's [ __ ] you know that's a
mentality yeah i hey
in your defense i have to say
that every
coco when they towed his house he was
living in my place he told the car they
told his house and so i got my car towed
so i can go in and get it okay
and when i went in there i got all his
clothes and everything and by the way i
checked the glove box and it was like
opening up one of them can of [ __ ]
snakes on springs you know what i'm
talking about
all them tickets fell out [ __ ]
it was like an encyclopedia fell the
[ __ ] out i mean the whole
all i mean it was just like it kept on
coming late it was like you clear a
bunch out and it was still [ __ ] a
[ __ ] ton in there so it was like one a
day for like three months dude three or
four the whole summer because the car
got towed
the car got towed probably november and
i started with that car in july or in
[ __ ] june
and they started ticketing me to
mid-july and then i lived by sammy
medina what's his name joy medina i'm
blind yeah oh bro you have no [ __ ]
idea i looked all over there where
ralphie first lived yeah ralphie moved
out and then joey needed a roommate and
i went over [ __ ] that you should have
like bought new license plates off
clinton dog there was no money for life
do you not listen you're getting 15 a
spot you're getting 40 at [ __ ] uh uh
yeah
rose mean [ __ ] um alhambra
west covina clothes on the road corona
you bought clothes on the [ __ ] road
lee you took a bus they used to drive me
to take a bus to el paso that was their
job
to joe diaz expressed monday nights to
be in el paso
tuesday morning at one in the afternoon
do you understand what commitment is for
550 dollars
yeah [ __ ] one two three four five six
[ __ ] shows in those days you pay your
75 a [ __ ] cent if you bought a
southwest flight that was half your
[ __ ] yeah there it goes so for you to
snort coke and go to taco cabana and
party you had to take the [ __ ] bus
so he used to book me for two weeks and
i'd still come home [ __ ] broke
[ __ ] crate
it's it's sickening what we did in the
name of comedy and partying i'm not
gonna lie to you but the whole time i
was serious about it that's why i could
have party at the store i was still
serious about it i just had the party
element to me and in those days i'll
pass them they were given
yeah man it was
i got i would get offered coke uh like
six seven times a night in el paso and i
never took it i never i never wanted to
get a taste for it cause i afraid i was
gonna love it too much all right and and
that kills fat people you know let me
just tell you let me just tell you
how weird the road is so i'm in el paso
and it's my birthday
i'm an old pass on it's my birthday and
it's a monday we just did the week and
i'm staying for another week
and i got a call on saturday night from
ralphie mayne jody ferdick
this is 1998.
i get a call from ralphie may and jody
fruit they're coming down they're going
back to l.a but they're coming down
to hang out on sunday with me for my
birthday so it was me and noah gonzalez
opening up for carlos mencia
and that was like a good money week for
me because you stayed on sunday and you
did three shows on saturday and opened
up the carlos this is 98.
what's his name really like me uh the
owner he had bart reed bart reed
so he would try to put me with the
bigger names and he kept telling me i'm
going to have you open up for cause i'm
like carla's not going to go for it he
don't like me well there's one time
carlos said yeah but i had to work with
noah and i loved knowing from the store
i loved knowing sure was happening
forever so it was my birthday on a
sunday it was ralphies on friday yeah
and
we were going they were going to come
down sunday night
oh yeah and jody got into a fight with
carlos yeah yes there you go oh man bro
i got a memory like a [ __ ] heart bro
she called him out on her [ __ ] i'll give
her they were playing nintendo in our
room
yeah why is carlos who's got a five-star
hotel across town and our [ __ ] comedy
condo
playing [ __ ] nintendo with noey
yeah nobody's smoking he's drinking or
nothing you're on the you're on the
floor i'm in the room
i'm on the couch i gave the bed to jody
there was two bedrooms
and this is the old comedy condo yeah
not the last yes the one by the
supermarket yes sir and her and carlos
got into it but the next morning
greatest the next morning we woke up we
didn't have much money i think we went
to arby's no we went to a mexican place
and and they make these [ __ ] fried
tacos that they do in el paso i thought
we went to harvard
because i met you guys by arby's yeah i
walked down the hill right you buy
arby's yeah because you couldn't find
them right you brought your car and jody
brought her a car yep you had you guys
were coming back to move here or
something like that okay
so we go what are we gonna do well let's
go to the [ __ ] movies oh and payback
was in the movie theater man and lucy
luke had us all boned up we were all
horny looking at lucy lou karate
chopping [ __ ] it was awesome
i love that [ __ ] this is 1998 it's 2015
guys just to show you guys the comedy
journey of broke comics we're on the
movie theater and it's there's got to be
maybe 16 people in the movie did so one
o'clock matinee on a monday yeah
and whatever the [ __ ] we ate
i ripped her far away oh
lee and it went
and then it just paused and i went
lee everybody looked at ralphie right
yeah i mean everybody
by the way okay it was like shooting
shooting shooting explosions explosions
and it stopped boom dead [ __ ] silence
it was the greatest fart timing of all
time my godly okay
everybody's looking at me okay and then
coco goes
god damn it ralphie my jesus christ
jesus [ __ ] christ
he's yelling it all right and
everybody's looking at me he's going i
didn't set it and we're [ __ ] howling
i'm howling inside because
where's tony better that guy
so funny
and then we went to the movies in
universal city
when i threw the eminem up and i hit
that ball guys
we threw peanut m ms at this
[ __ ] because his head looked
like a peanut m my oblong all right and
we just see the movie and every now and
then you see just
that big ass eminem fly the [ __ ] up in
the air
okay bounced off the light all right and
he was like looking back like who done
it oh my god and we were leaving there
and his head had candy okay had candy
like like different colors and he was
convention to the manager hell somebody
this is this discount to these teenagers
[ __ ] eminem
we're walking out we forgot all about
that we threw a peanut on this
[ __ ] all i know is lee the
peanut the peanut bounced off his head
like three feet he looked up right
how many times do you spoken about them
oh like 15. right it was a whole ticket
they would give two m ms it was a
promotion so it was two of those bags m
m's and even though we were high where
fat [ __ ] we're like we don't need a
[ __ ] whole another bag of m m's
because i just want to keep going
yeah give me those
whipping them during the [ __ ] parts of
the movie how old are you at this point
this is 10 years ago 10 years ago i'm 33
yeah 40 i'm 39 who gives a [ __ ] right
i'm just high having a great time here
but here's the whole thing
we hit him with the thing because his
head looks like an emperor
he's
around weirdest [ __ ] looking oh my
he
looking
god
we had to beat him because the light was
bomb shining off his head yeah
we hit him and that's it we move on with
our lives we're watching the movie
two hours later we're walking out of
this movie feeling like nothing happened
we forgot all about the peanut insert
and the guy's got the beat on his hand
and he's giving her a beat imagine
how these guys hit me with and we're
[ __ ] howling
i'm hiding
i'm [ __ ] howling right there in the
guy's face he had to know it was uh
what the [ __ ] did you ever hit nobody
with a peanut oh yeah but not no i mean
it's hysterical but i just i can't
imagine you two
just
oh yeah man we hit him good too he was
like oh and and we were having a contest
like how far could we bounce the [ __ ]
him and him off his head
and it would hit him and bounce off his
head straight up like three or four feet
that's what [ __ ] kills you ladies oh
man and you can see the peanut flying in
the light from the [ __ ] theater oh it
was beautifully it was so funny
hey man okay i gotta tell you how about
the time that annoying [ __ ] [ __ ]
was at the comedy store telling us he
was a fox tv guy all right and he's a
producer okay all right and we just got
[ __ ] sick of this [ __ ] always
critiquing us never calling us in for
this and you're like ralphie look at
this all right and you put like a
thousand [ __ ] snots on this asshole's
jacket a thousand snots
okay all right and i'm i'm laughing
going i bet those snots are worth 85
bucks if we grind them up
leave for about a year for years i would
put snots on people it started with this
teacher in high school mr zinc
and i hung out with his daughter susie
zing she was [ __ ] a great friend of
mine we were yeah
this guy had a suit and i would tap him
on the shoulder i would pick a snack and
tap him on the shoulder mr zinc was
happening and you would see the snots
he'd wear the same jacket every day so
that's the first guy in the bar that
would snot
and then when i was in colorado the
funniest thing one of the funniest
things i've ever seen i always wanted
this guy to call onto the podcast
this is a guy that i didn't do comedy
but he became my friend along the way he
was a brother of a friend of mine
in colorado and one morning i did a
quaalude it was the night before
thanksgiving and what were those like oh
my god it was the night before
thanksgiving this is what happened
i moved to aspen in april of 83.
and by [ __ ] september i was lonely
guys you know i'm a [ __ ] 19 year old
kid 19 year old kid in [ __ ] colorado
i just came from new york robbing [ __ ] i
just robbed a jewelry store i was
building a reputation and [ __ ] was by
the way was that when george was the
getaway driver but he didn't know no no
no no no that was when jimmy
and he listens to that no no timmy no
george was the getaway driver for the
gas station yeah and he didn't even know
he was he was all heroined out
i love it what were we talking about i'm
sorry aspen colorado no we were talking
we were homesick i was really [ __ ]
homesick
and there was a guy
that had a little hotel across the
street from
at this place it was called the in and
out sandwich shop and that's the first
place ralphie may i ever tasted
like turkey with avocado and
french ranch dr uh french dressing
like the red one russian dress
oh my god all healthy in fact the guy
comes to my shows in buffalo we
reconnected in 1983 but across the
street was a chateau and in front of it
was a hitching post that you could sit
there in aspen colorado downtown and
people would pull over if you were going
down valley this meant down valley this
meant the short way this could be like
snowmass village and they pull up and go
where you going woody creek i'm going to
snowmass village hop in you could take a
bus down to woody creek that's 83.
so i went up then i became friends and
the guy that owned the hotel he was from
jersey but he was friends at the time
with a philadelphia eagle
that lived next door to me like what a
small world i moved from [ __ ] jersey
to basalt
and the guy next to me is like an eagle
from this from 68. wow and he was still
big he looked like uh christopher i
don't remember what his [ __ ] name was
and him and his wife were good friends
with my buddies from jersey so i became
friends with them so all of a sudden i'm
in aspen one day in front of the
hitching post and i become friends with
the guy that owns the hotel
and one day i'm in front of the hotel
and the [ __ ] football player pulls up
and gives me a ride and we all start
talking he goes you know joey yeah
so next time i see this guy he goes come
into my house
and we start talking he goes taste his
blow
so he gives me some [ __ ] blow and now
we become friends every time i go in
there i go in get a package from him
then one day he kept telling me i got
heroin
i got he had all those designer pills in
the 80s i mean this guy was the guy he
had a hotel
and one night he goes you know i got
quaaludes
i was like what do you want from them at
the time i was paying for in aspen there
were 10
and they were far six for 50. so i said
give me [ __ ] six of them oh what a
mistake that was and i went to my own
apartment they were having a party where
i lived my roommate was having a party
where i [ __ ] lived
and i went over there there was a cake
there was vodka and i popped one of
those gorilla biscuits
and next thing you know i woke up the
next morning i kept hearing an accent
uh-huh a north carolina accent and some
good man i'm telling you ohio state
ain't [ __ ] the tar heels is the only way
to go you're all a bunch of
[ __ ] [ __ ] and i get up to
see he was yelling in my living room
it's this kid from north carolina
a white dude tall just a redneck opie
taylor looking freckles and [ __ ]
and i had to sit down with him and argue
with him a little bit we always became
[ __ ] goombas i don't know what the
point of the story is what i'm telling
you about carlos
man i wanted him to call in oh yeah what
happened with the about five six
quarters
i ate one of those [ __ ] gorilla
biscuits what do you wake up in like
north carolina no i woke up in asheville
it's no mess village in my living room
oh okay
man wasn't it good was it a good ride
those things
he doesn't know i mean no [ __ ] yeah i
know oh my god
quaaludes hit quaaludes were huge in the
cocaine when cocaine merged with studio
54. right it was the fine and the load
right it was the quaalude the tumenol
and something else there was something
else in those days uh
but the quaalude was the aurora and the
lemon but they were both 7 14s
i still remember the distinct memory of
being on the corner of 43rd street in
front of my friend didi quintero's house
and this guy richie scravati pulling up
and looking at me and going what are you
doing i'm like none i was 16
and he goes you want to go ludi
and that meant do you want to do a loot
and me indeed he got in the car with him
[ __ ] ate a loot it was tremendous
those days you ate a loot and drank one
cocktail and you got [ __ ] up like you
didn't puke
you just lost your body gumby you
you know you loved everybody
you loved everybody you know what i'm
saying everybody was your goomba they
hugged you
drinks you ever get cosby
no
no no and then you took them with the
blow okay to calm you down the mindset
was that they calm you down but the more
blow you did the more those gorilla
biscuits you ate
i told the joke on stage at the comedy
store it didn't work but it really did
happen to a friend of mine he left the
house with a hundred quaaludes and a
bicycle and he came back with a
handlebar and stitches and not a dime
because
once you built the tolerance to him it
was a tolerance like anything else lee
built the tolerance of thc 200
milligrams isn't really killing him
tonight right now he's usually dead but
eventually you build a tower plus all
the weed we smoked but it's you build it
and the hash because it's hash monday
but it also had you had two effects in
those days and this is the truth you had
i personally never knew anybody
who dosed a chick like cosby was doing i
get to give you my word crazy but i i
had a girlfriend that i take them with
her
yeah i take a half and we drink harvey's
bristol cream and do a couple lines and
the sex would be out of this world i
guess
you know yes i've always been bad in bed
so what about [ __ ] house but
unless i miss like heard the story
didn't the cosby girl say like they
passed out so it doesn't sound like quit
unless you unless you give them like a
listen if i give a 140 pound girl a
[ __ ] quaalude the ones i was getting
in those days yeah
listen i was getting quaaludes on the
street
but then when i became 18
i was getting some qualities up on 68th
street from this chick that was a punk
rock chick
everybody else had brown hair and this
[ __ ] had purple hair and she was chubby
and let me just break it down to you
this way guys her brother
you could look him up on wikipedia he's
the real [ __ ] deal and he was
older than i was but he was a tremendous
basketball player and when we were kids
we used to talk on the phone i had no
idea about his family's affiliation
but here it is plain and simple the
quaaludes i got from her
were the best things i ever ever ate in
my life
and the word on the street listen
everybody lies about drugs
it's like the doctors okay dog ralphie
how's your knee
fine coco i didn't know if i tell you i
got the best third and everybody got the
best surgery this guy worked on
challenge bronson this guy did the front
lines
you know this guy this guy operated
jesus when he came back you know
everybody's got the best [ __ ] surgeon
everybody's got the best dentist mike
and ben
and you know i asked jim kellen the wig
jim you know any dentist he sent me to a
dentist that would cost you 300 just to
walk into the office in bella hills
because he does the chicken i've got my
dentist in nashville and he's helped a
bunch of comedians and brothers of mine
now go in there and uh get their dental
work and
it's he is [ __ ] the best he's a black
dentist we call him the unicorn because
i never [ __ ] met a black dentist
before him but he's a bad [ __ ]
every chick in there is a [ __ ] dime
all right his his wife looks like
michelle obama all right i mean she fine
too all right he drives old hot rods
he's a bad [ __ ] all right what's
it going to do with quails hey hey i'll
hook you up you said about dennis i
actually got a guy when you go to
tennessee
my point is everybody always says
hollywood for a dentist
i'm scared i go down the corner from my
house the little iranian guy i'll give
you the arabian guy that [ __ ]
beats insurance every time this guy
comes to me and he goes i could get you
this this this next you know i see him
next time he's listening i got your
[ __ ] rebate don't worry about the
[ __ ] 200. that's what they do they
work the system yeah right the way
you're supposed to yeah but so this girl
for years kept telling me
these things are pharmaceutical i would
go to a meal like at seven o'clock on
friday and get and everybody else wanted
four
in the mid 80s in 81 and 82 this [ __ ]
wanted six
but i mean they came with a rapper jack
like sealed and she'd tell you they were
pharmaceuticals and those things if you
look at my eyes i have veins that busted
there from those
things i know for a fact i remember that
the first time i ate one of her bills i
still remember uniquely that night i
stayed on 46th street hill and it was
the dead of the winter and in those days
we barely had you know we'd buy a nickel
bag of weed
we'd buy a bottle of pupa vodka or wolf
schmidt silver
we've got a
mixer gatorade or orange juice and in
those days we didn't have enough for
blow so the kid i hung out with his
brother was a slinger so we'd stay at
his house our goal was to stay up until
2 2 30 because when carlos would come
home he'd give us each a little line we
were 15. dede was maybe 13. wow and
carlos would give us a little line and
go get the [ __ ] out of my room i got a
girl coming over and that was it we'd do
a quail but
one friday in particular me and this kid
ate one of those pills and went back to
his house and we put on led zeppelin
three particularly gallows paul
we listened to gallows pole
a thousand
[ __ ] times put on gallows polly such
a strong gallows pole led zeppelin three
we put that song on
ralphie a thousand times and we sat in
his brother's room with the lights dim
and we just drank smoke dope
and listen to this [ __ ] song over and
over and over i remember the brother
coming giving me a lot of coke in those
days my mother had just died i was
living with the benders
and i'd walk over to uh
the bender's [ __ ] jazzed up at four
in the morning what are they gonna say
to me they weren't my parents i was just
living there
all night i listened to this song
way looted up the next one i woke up i
had [ __ ] my eyes were bloodshot and
there's veins that stayed purple
like they just stayed like that and that
was the end of that's the story of the
[ __ ] vein in my eyes
[ __ ]
at this time tomorrow in 12 hours i'll
be fainting
oh really i got a physical and a finger
up the ass tomorrow the chest x-ray
and everything i gotta clean my ears
what's gonna make you paint the finger
the blood but i'm charging the ipod
right now the last couple of times let
me see for the heart thing i went into
complications
i always go in the combo okay whatever i
have complications
they stuck the
when they stuck this and
for the [ __ ] thing with my heart the
ink i got a little they were they didn't
know what was going on then i i just
breathe through my nose and i'm fine
when i did it for the the two the camera
in my [ __ ] and they put the
intravenous in
that time they had to turn the air
conditioning and they just went and
[ __ ] them profusely in there tomorrow
they if they put me in the room with no
windows i have a hard time
but if they put me in the room with
window if i could see light
what i do is i go in there first and i
set up the [ __ ] cut how i like it
when i light the pillow i swear to god i
run that [ __ ] bob hope medical center
dr wexler is my [ __ ] main man
so he's not even in the room yet when he
comes he goes what do you want to do
first they throw a [ __ ]
a sheet on you you got to take your
underwear off tomorrow it's a [ __ ]
nightmare tomorrow
and he'll look at my ears he'll look at
my nose i trim my nose hairs today he'll
look under my armpits he'll feel me for
[ __ ] lumps whatever the [ __ ] he does
he'll make me show him my dick and he'll
[ __ ] grab my balls and make me cough
and then he's talking to me let me check
your lungs with that
with that you know breathe for me and
while he's breathing he'll go right bend
over and while he's making me breathe
he'll take a deep breath and also not
feel a cold finger with lube going into
my ass
and you could hear him fishing in there
like looking for a watch
and all of a sudden he's like you're
okay and after that there's not much you
could say yeah right are you okay it's
gonna be a [ __ ] minute
am i okay you just [ __ ] destroyed my
hopes at 9 15 in the [ __ ] morning now
i gotta go down the hill and let this
[ __ ] take blood out of me which is now
even more mortifying now i gotta breathe
and sit down but who's gonna sit down i
just had a finger up my ass i can't even
[ __ ] sit down it's so embarrassing so
now they take me into another [ __ ]
room after that so i did two tests right
so now they take blood out so now what i
do is i go in there first they usually
want to put me in the dungeon next to a
chest x-rays but there's no windows in
there it's one of those school [ __ ]
chairs last time i did that was in
prison i didn't like it
i go on the back and there's a [ __ ]
cot and i [ __ ] fix it the right way
there's a little bit light and [ __ ]
there's a sink in there it's an
examination room but it's right adjacent
to it
and i get on that [ __ ] correctly
and i put my ipod on dog and i don't
hear nothing
and i leave my arm out and i just look
the other way
and i just leave it there and then she
comes in and i'll tell her listen use
the kid needle on me and spray the lick
of cocaine on my arm
and she'll say no problem
and then she'll come over and she'll go
you're gonna be fine and i'll just start
breathing out of my nose and i'll put
santana or jacob over
and i just keep
that's it that's it and she'll lift up
my arm and dog if she does the tape and
i
i'm okay i gotta get up slow i'll stop
and get a can of diet coke to give me a
little pep to my step after that because
the coke is too sweet that'll [ __ ]
give me diabetes right off the chart and
then i walk down the hall and they do a
chest x-ray and once i'm done i put my
clothes and i get the [ __ ] out of it and
then i go around the corner of the
mimi's and i get two eggs and i get some
toast because i deserve that nourishment
i haven't eaten i can't eat after
midnight tonight so what are you going
to have when you get home i'm protein
shake with no sugar in it because i
don't want to raise my sugar levels i
can't even put a [ __ ] banana in there
fruit but why don't you you'll be home
before midnight yeah it doesn't matter i
could eat before midnight but i don't
want to put like anything in my like if
i eat a milkshake tonight my sugar level
is going to be high then he's going to
make me come in there in two weeks
because he thinks i got [ __ ] diabetes
and i got to go and then do the whole
[ __ ] test over because i want to go
hang out with you at north hollywood
dine and have a vanilla milkshake kind
of stuff which i would kill for right
now but yeah my point is i just don't
want to do one time that sounds strong i
didn't [ __ ] think about it like a
milkshake i'm a bad fat guy i went in my
trunk to get something right before i'm
in the doctor i go hold on one second
i'm under my trunk
this about a year ago you know how much
i hate needles
i went in my [ __ ] trunk my wife comes
down there with me i get out of bob hope
and she goes did you find that thing go
hold on i left in the trunk and i opened
the trunk like oh my god that pot
cookies in here and you know me no no no
please don't leave you know how much of
a [ __ ] momo i am without even i can't
have a milkshake but listen to me lee
this is at eight in the [ __ ] morning
without realizing it i take the cookie
open it up and take a bite out of the
[ __ ] pot cookie
and i go inside and i sit down i go that
[ __ ] cookie is going to raise my
blood my sugar level in my blood and
sure enough joey diaz jose i go to the
[ __ ] thing they take my blood two
days later who's on the [ __ ] phone dr
wexler listen
you got diabetes no i don't i ate a
[ __ ] [ __ ] cookie before i went in and
raised my [ __ ] sugar levels he goes
well you gotta better come down here and
prove it to me i had to go back down
there again give him blood again
and then he was like you're right don't
eat a [ __ ] cookie before you come see
me
yeah so that's why i'm just gonna have a
milkshake they got no sugar in this
protein shake
i got no carbs i won't put fruit in it
and i'll just go to bed my hope is that
i sleep till six
or seven that's my big [ __ ] dilemma
here tonight
i gotta sleep till seven so i don't
think about it if i get up at five i'm
[ __ ] because i gotta eat
what's going through your head like it
when like the
taking blood and you pass out like
what's going on like what do you get
what like what what part of it makes you
nervous lee i get can i just uh kind of
answer that because oh i hate needles i
i don't know what's going through his
head but when it was we were at ufc and
i had to hold him the [ __ ] up
okay
uh i know what the [ __ ] was going
through my head coco come back all right
and then he was all right but he got
lightheaded oh my god
they wiped the kid's face oh
and the towel i looked at the towel yeah
oh my god and i focused on the towel and
had blood on it like maybe
two months maybe
four months before that i was at home
watching the ufc and b.j penn fought joe
whatever and they were fighting he
busted his head and that's the most
blood i ever saw in my life and i passed
that on my couch
and then i go to a ufc and i focus on
the towel and i [ __ ] lost it lee that
guy ralph was there and there was a
chick next to me with huge fake tits she
was a doctor oh my gosh she was a man
and that's what [ __ ] happened brother
so no but like you said if you wake up
early tomorrow you're gonna like it's
gonna worry you like what like what
freaks you out
just first off when i don't eat after an
hour in the morning i might go somewhere
else i need something a bowl of [ __ ]
cereal
you know i'm not gonna eat something
shitty but i'll eat like an apple
something some water and an apple just
to wake up and not be able to eat for
two hours then go down there and do what
i hate the most give blood and the
finger of diaz a double dilemma
and once they put the finger up yes it
just jams up your electrodes trust me
wait till you turn 50. you're going to
think about what i told you for people
at home they don't know what i'm saying
they're like what are you talking about
it like jams you up for a minute
especially if that's not your world
if that's not your world the first time
that i i was remember i was going to
testosterone doctor and he was listening
i got bad news my partner wants to see i
go all right i didn't even [ __ ] i
walk like i take a [ __ ] that morning i
wipe my ass but you know sometimes you
take a [ __ ] and leave some in your
little muffler and i go to this doctor
and he's like come in the back i got to
check you out
you're not drawing blood he goes no i
gotta check down he goes turn around
and i remember him putting those tooth
and i could hear like the
leftover that was in there i didn't want
to look at the glove they take it out
this guy ripped me apart
he had his finger deep in there and he
was looking for [ __ ]
and i was like did he find it i don't
know lee i almost passed out i've had
that twice oh man i've had that twice
it's not my world people so please don't
think i'm uh
you never had a girl do that to you no
guy what the hell is wrong with you i'm
a catholic
yeah we all find your line now that's
your fun it's just
it's not a girl or it's not a it's just
something it just feels weird it just
feels [ __ ] it's the weirdest feeling
i ever had like it made me feel weird
and i'm prepared for it tomorrow
let's not get in my [ __ ] car get on
the one-on-one i come home and i move on
i just want to be able to do [ __ ] the
rest of the day tomorrow i don't like
fainting in the morning it kind of ruins
my [ __ ] day you know i can't see that
yeah
so let me ask you something all of a
sudden i don't know where special pops
up on netflix that you taped in vegas
why did you tape this with a [ __ ]
add-on like a magician
i taped it um as part of a deal uh with
a production company and i uh recorded
it at the uh
southpointe casino and uh spa it's a
fantastic place go there and um
i uh
i put it out and
netflix they saw me and i had it for
free i had it i had it all done it was
part of a deal i'd host uh one of those
shows and they would give me this and i
was like sure no problem
and um we did uh we did we we had it
fully done and then netflix goes hey uh
we we they saw me at the wild west
comedy fest in in nashville and they
they gave me a big deal and they go for
two specials and i go i'll deliver both
in november and they're like and it was
like
a month and a half later and they're
going no way and i go i guaran [ __ ]
tee it and i gave them to
uh
the like by the 15th of december
and uh they they put the uh unruly out
first and then they did a soft on and
perfectly yours because they thought it
was a smaller venue but they liked the
material so you know i i'm just very
fortunate netflix is sponsoring on my
fall tour i've got 80 theaters i'm doing
across north america and i'm coming to a
place near you when do you start the
tour
um coco we start in
uh
it's it's warming up now with a couple
of club dates like i'm getting the new
show down okay is what i'm working on
right now um in san jose uh this week
it's kind of a mini theater and so it'll
start giving me the feel like and then
and then utah i'm there i'm warming up
because i want a [ __ ] a tough
audience and there's a lot of mormons
and jack mormons come out and i'm
controversial and they don't like that
[ __ ] all right and then i want to i want
to work on my mexican stuff in phoenix
and then they all start
all over the country i think i've got
mondays off
and then there's like a week in october
i'll be back and you'll be back here
yeah man look at yeah tip top [ __ ]
magu out there letting these
[ __ ] know yeah man i gotta
finance my [ __ ] car i'm i'm buying a
i mean i've bought the car what i'm
getting i'm making i'm redoing a 67 uh
gto convertible all right and it's gonna
be a rocket ship coco and but that cost
a lot of [ __ ] money you know i mean
so it's like i gotta get my ass out
there and do some goddamn jokes i gotta
do something man
you're still out there ralphie it's hard
to believe we were those same kids at
that movie theater farting oh so funny
giggling it really is lee it's a [ __ ]
weird thing
well we always had heart thing man
i mean how like we said it a thousand
times before but it must be crazy like
when you have friends like you and moz
and and all you guys and
maybe you're maybe
one out of 20 i guess all of you i mean
how could you not have fond memories you
know mike faberman called me today how
long have i known
how many [ __ ] laughs we had in this
bag oh my god oh my god how many [ __ ]
you know that magic shoe box and these
comics are still here yeah and some of
them have disappeared and you go on
facebook and you find them or they pop
up on somebody's page and you go there
you are yeah and they're back in toledo
wherever the [ __ ] they are but right
it's this is a weird [ __ ] journey man
it really
what the [ __ ] knows you just get into
something
and it takes you to a different place
who would have [ __ ] know i know man
if i hadn't had lana i wouldn't have got
last comic
and then i i'd be like everybody else
barely getting by
that's all the difference is
that's the truth
you know i mean it's it's uh
uh that's why there's no prenup with me
in the jew okay there's nothing okay
it's it's 50 50 all the way
you know there's no getting out of it
there's no getting around it you know
she [ __ ] earned it actually she'd
probably get 60 40 to me
okay without her i would never have been
able to do it
at least you know that going in that's
true that's true
but when you're that honest with things
and you give an honest appraisal to
where your career is it just baffles you
that she's not further along she's great
you know more than anybody i'm here
because of my wife yeah right we're
talking about the update giggling i'm
here because of my wife the one t i
won't throw away that tv
the first tv i bought with a 200 mile tv
up and uh after one of those gigs for
500
up at oxnard or some [ __ ]
we stopped at a walmart the tv didn't
fit in the [ __ ] back seat the neon
it's crazy i won't get rid of it i
refuse to get rid of it she's like you
got to get rid i ain't getting rid of
that thing that thing still [ __ ]
plays
that thing was the backbone of the
organization you know how many [ __ ]
you know how many uh episodes are low
and all that thing played for us
while we're eating a [ __ ]
turkey sandwich with american cheese or
something do you have any [ __ ] idea
you just can't give something up like
that that that symbolism to me i
remembered all those things man
i never forgot them i don't know why and
i bet i did forget a lot of those
road memories but man
that i luck out on the [ __ ] road just
putting pieces together as a feature act
going up to boston and working for
[ __ ]
all those clubs 50 bugs nicks and
uh the grill 57 i was taking buses
everywhere i would go online and catch
how lones
[ __ ] yeah man oh my god i was going up
to uh
rhode island toronto in those days all
that bustley
all the way down the [ __ ] dc is
expressing tyson's corner bethesda then
i'd shoot down a myrtle beach and then i
i'd know atlanta in those days the
punchline hated me so i shoot down the
[ __ ] uh
uh the other club hated me in
jacksonville
the the hilton whatever with all you
could eat
it's the comedy zone and it's run by mr
fred all right and and every time i go
in there they have a great [ __ ]
buffet on fridays or fridays and friday
nights [ __ ] tremendous okay
all right and
i remember he came in all right and uh
said that we had to pay for that and
it's like and i've had [ __ ] eight
sold out shows in two days okay and i'm
like hey go [ __ ] yourself we're gonna
murder this goddamn place and when they
brought me the tab i just said give this
to fred that was it and i cracked him
right there
still has it still rocking i think it's
one of the nicest [ __ ] hotels in
ramada's chain they're [ __ ] great the
mandarin yeah the mandarine the
mandarine yes
yeah and it is
it is [ __ ] tremendous and they had a
place around the corner after you did
the mansion in there was a bar where you
went and did karaoke yeah and got blow
and got [ __ ] up stuff
stanhope was the king of that king of
that bar man think of that [ __ ] they
still have his picture up with the long
hair when he was a [ __ ] baby when he
had hope for life all right
when he had a lust for life and wanted
to do something aspire to greater thanks
then i would do it i would do one or two
coconuts to keep me alive to give me
change
to get me all the way to miami i didn't
i did everything that's for garbage oh
my god i did davey wavy and davey was
the name of the club no no no it was
[ __ ] wavy and davey i did it three
times and davey was the club your boy
owned
yeah and he had that one like yeah
in
1998 i co-headlined it with
jim florentina weehawk in new jersey
yeah and the comedy condo didn't have a
[ __ ] bathroom on a door on the
bathroom
it was the worst comedy condo and i had
to stay with like cousins and they were
living like animals like 22 to a bedroom
snort and blow it was tremendous
and then i finally got into the miami
improv yeah and then that was joel
chadwick joe chadwick he's in cleveland
somewhere selling his shoes
because his wife and his wife finally
died they got like oh man they got like
three million dollars they they got that
thing fen fent mm-hmm they sued fenfan
and got like three million dollars and
went through it in two weeks
and then she died and
it's weird this comedy stuff is weird
when you get into like the people that
are still around and who's moved on
right
like whatever happened to mark babbitt
he's hoteling it his hotel let me give
him some shout outs i'm gonna do the
sponsors all right man loving you all
right my main man major slander sean
taft
danielle gantt
omar habubi
i'm not gonna get to the book yet don
wrangler joey v the stefano mark cicero
callie george sarcastic best and
moonspoor 85. i love your [ __ ]
all right
what's up with you dog what are you
sitting there all hypnotized for like
biggie
did you know he shot some dude with aids
blood
oh
[ __ ] um not biggie [ __ ] what's his
name who's the guy that got run over my
what my whatever shirt
what the movie
who who just
cat williams manager what's what's his
name suge knight sugar knight
that he shot some dude with a aids blood
where did you hear this
uh the paul was talking about the movie
it's like that rapper or something
yeah like one of the one of the
conspiracy theories is that chuck knight
did it
i don't know
anyone ever heard about it i just heard
that for the first time yeah you're
blowing my mind you didn't go see you
didn't go see straight like content no
yeah good reviews i think we're gonna go
tomorrow
what time are you going i have no idea
you're taking paul yeah
tomorrow night yeah probably after
kettlebells look at you you're [ __ ] i
love it latin love that [ __ ] yeah what
have you heard so far
it's good people say it's good did she
see it paula no not yet
but and i'll see it i saw dope that was
good have you seen that yet no it was
really good what is it about it was
about this like um this like nerdy black
kid in
inglewood
and uh i was i'm really high so i don't
remember the rest of it but it was good
it was kind of around the same
like he was like nerdy i don't know what
he was doing oh yeah he he he got a bag
from a drug dealer and they wanted to
get him
that's a great story yeah that's that's
really it this is what happens why are
you going to bother me with this [ __ ]
for what are you asking questions
good conversation
you give me all this [ __ ]
all you gotta say is i haven't seen it
but thinking like i don't know about
strain that content but i know about the
movie though i saw that it's about a kid
who bought a bag of dope and moved on
whether everybody buys a bag of dope lee
that's all you got for me you watch the
whole [ __ ] movie
you're high as [ __ ] oh you're so [ __ ]
crazy
i'm crazy
all i ask do you see stranded like a cop
did your wife see it no not yet so how
does she know about the blood scene
oh no no she was just reading stuff
about that it's not in the movie so what
is she [ __ ] reading for
i don't know
people like to read stories so she read
before she went to the movies
yeah sure oh my gosh yeah you got to
talk though you got to sit down it's not
about the movie it is about them who
gives a [ __ ] you go to she's doing
research on the [ __ ] thing she's an
attorney she hasn't read enough
you haven't read enough you're going to
read for [ __ ] the next 20 years you
want to read with some [ __ ] movies
about they made the movie you want to
read the book because you want to go to
starbucks and tell your friends who
gives a [ __ ] go see the movie and take a
shortcut
like the rest of america
more smoke some more ash sure why not
this [ __ ] hashes
ladies and gentlemen
look at that where did you get that from
coco that [ __ ] is the one
we're gonna put it on i was i'm telling
tanya
we need a glass
we got that cup it's dirty as [ __ ]
then they drink wine
[ __ ] cup of glass i forgot to bring
them i was going to put on this needle
and hit that [ __ ] and then push
the glass and take the smoked paper wish
we had some reefer we'd put it on top of
some reef and make a cuban sandwich nah
you want me to taste some i was doing
that for a couple weeks this hash is too
good you could smoke this hash on a
little pipe and get [ __ ] up take a
couple hits it expands in your lungs
nice like lee likes lee likes when he
expands his [ __ ] lumps i did i had
dabs explained to me and
apparently the butane isn't bad
like he was saying it just it gets
cooked off so there's nothing in it yeah
it burns so high so
but yeah i i actually like them in
toronto it was pretty cool
i just think that shit's dangerous yeah
i can't have i i would burn my house
down dude that's what i'm afraid of
people are gonna burn their [ __ ]
houses down doing that [ __ ] man well no
but the guy the guy who was there had
one that was battery operated that was
apparent apparently even stronger so
there's ways to do it but that's just
too much work for me yeah man i mean you
gotta have a torch i mean [ __ ] it if i
pass out on the head the lighter goes
out
you know what i mean it's like what the
[ __ ] i i gotta i gotta clean up bond
water that's it
you know that's the only problem
and it's like
this shit's dangerous you gotta [ __ ] a
torch it's just so crazy how history
repeats itself
in 1982
uh
i was i just graduated some kid picked
me up steve vadalanis
and he's like i hear you selling coke i
got this pimp who wants to bite coke he
buys coke all day for his a true story
he buys coke all day for his hoover's
okay
pick us up steve valence he picks this
up me rajan we drive down there
and that's the guy who kept saying every
time he made a turn he'd go that was
tremendous
that was tremendous
that right turn was tremendous
this cocaine was tremendous
the view is tremendous this pimp is
tremendous everything's a pretty nice
pimp
everything was [ __ ] tremendous
he was a goofy bottom [ __ ]
tremendous jackson we get to the [ __ ]
hotel room he's staying off of tunnel
avenue off to 1-9 there i'm 18. we're
going into this guy's pimp he's got
these hookers and he's like listen i
want the best coke available because i
cook it up
so i go taste this he tested he goes oh
that shit's like 80 whatever i buy what
you got he bought he goes you want to
take a hit of this [ __ ] i took a hit a
bit
was i impressed guys
it took me eight months to get high on
coke
that's how much of a fiend that was for
eight months i thought people were lying
to me
i thought people were putting me on i
would do coke and nothing would happen
to me
and everybody else would be [ __ ] this
is great and i'd be sitting there going
oh jesus
these [ __ ] saps
are paying fifty dollars just to tell
people they're getting high but then i
did something i had a drink one night
and once i had the alcohol and my system
of coke hit me and i was like oh
i get it now i gotta drink a little
vodka to get this [ __ ] cocaine
flowing
i don't remember when that story started
me neither who gives a [ __ ] i love it
that's the best thing about it so
i don't even know
why you gotta laugh like that for it
sounds like
look at the shape of this poor bastard
what's your wife making a turkey
sandwich
oh there's no [ __ ] turkey in there oh
my god if i want a turkey sandwich i'll
marry a chick named mary
i'm marrying the chicken i don't keep
connie inside out of my house well tell
her to [ __ ] walk over the house and
get you a nice little [ __ ] pig leg
and cook that [ __ ] up with some
garlic so when the master gets home
are you not the master or what what the
[ __ ] you don't put a cape on and tell
you the master disaster
walk around with your dick out and tell
her
i don't give a [ __ ] if you're the
attorney i'm the law you know what i'm
saying
you really i don't you got to represent
yourself out of sucking this mule
i made a jubilee i don't say that [ __ ]
oh i like all my stuff players
you're so fun to hang out with well he's
like hanging out i'm proud of lee for
going to toronto and taking a chance
good for you you know man uh you and i
have discussed heart for years and it
bothers you more than it bothers me yeah
people that complain but
at the end take me on the road how many
times you go out for spots this week
right but they just went specifically to
the comedy club that night to talk to
you right how bad their life was for you
to take them on the [ __ ] road with
them but in the meantime they don't want
to do nothing they don't want to [ __ ]
tape a five minutes out of their pizza
place they don't want to do a podcast
they don't want to do this room because
the owner is an [ __ ] and they they
don't want to do it for 50 bucks
you're [ __ ] dying on a vine when
you're dying on a vine you do whatever
they put in front of you because your
talent is the only one that's going to
gain yeah when i lived in seattle that
one woman laura crocker
god [ __ ] bless her soul in hell
[ __ ] uh
didn't like me
but she had dirty rooms she was josh
wolfe's manager yeah she had dirty
[ __ ] rooms guys
and good room so i would just call up
and go do you mind if i do a guessing in
your room
what's she going to say she'd go yeah
and i'd go down and do a guy said blow
up the room and the owner would go why
don't you work this room i tell him
laura don't like me
and and for months i did this and people
go why are you such an [ __ ] you're
doing this for free you should at least
be in 50 bucks and i go you don't
understand this is what i do i'm going
to get into an argument over 50 bucks i
go to another spot after this and now i
got two spots for the night which is the
goal of this that's the goal when you're
first starting out to get two or three
spots a night then you can really judge
your [ __ ] material and see what the
[ __ ] going on you learn that much
quicker you know that's what you have to
do that's what you have to [ __ ] do so
there's no getting around there's no
[ __ ] shortcut to the [ __ ] top of
the mountain you can put out as many
goddamn vines as you want you can
[ __ ] tweet all day long and half the
[ __ ] night and guess what you still
have to [ __ ] get behind the
microphone in front of live
[ __ ] and [ __ ] have new jokes
so many young comics they [ __ ] they
write their first five minutes and then
they
that they've never done before and then
they never do that again for another six
seven eight years do they start going up
with jokes that they've that that
they've never done before here's here's
five new minutes and it's like they
don't have balls they get afraid they're
gonna lose something they're not gonna
be funny if they don't it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know i mean these guys you
know you know that kid um uh matt rife
he's like 19. he's on that show wilding
out now and he's he's a good comic okay
he's not [ __ ] great but he is good
all right i met that kid when he was 16
in [ __ ] ohio he was hitting me up six
seven times a day on twitter facebook
everything asking for a [ __ ] guest
spot on my [ __ ] theater show and i'm
like i don't know about this
and then the [ __ ] showed up at
my bus at [ __ ] eight in the morning
with breakfast his mom brought [ __ ]
lemonade i'm like [ __ ] yeah kid you're
going up this is [ __ ] hard this is
some kid that wants to perform i put him
up and he rocked the [ __ ] blew
it up and and now he's doing tv but it's
that hard that initial [ __ ] nothing
can stop me from making my goals happen
okay that is something that all these
[ __ ]
of these [ __ ] young comics they're
just waiting for stuff to come to this
it's not even without a heart i saw a
lot of old oh my god a lot of my age
that have popped back up and
they're like listen can you do this and
you sit there and go where have you been
for eight years right you just stopped
you gave up you didn't keep going up
three times a week i understand you had
to get a day job yeah but you didn't
maintain this art this is what you did
for eight years you had a big investment
in this think about if you would have
put another eight years into it where
you would have been right now where you
would have [ __ ] been right now why do
you think i'd bug you about the jiu
jitsu lee
you think i'm buggy because i like
bugging you because john bud said you're
great you move great he goes oh he needs
to lose 40 pounds
he goes if lee keeps coming once a week
he's going to lose that 40 pounds and i
know that in a year you're gonna look at
me and go you know what i'm happy i got
friends now over there they call me up
they invite me to [ __ ] parties i'm
not the [ __ ] odd man out because
people gain respect for you in a way
you know you keep [ __ ] going over
there doesn't matter the same thing
applies to comedy or editing
or any of those [ __ ] things
that if you wouldn't have stopped doing
it at this time you would have been in
five more years right so at this point
you would have been doing comedy 10
years but you came out here went to
montreal got a deal
the deal didn't work out and you caved
a lot of people did that a lot of people
[ __ ] did that that's 50 percent of
the game once they tell them all you
need is three minutes five minutes go to
montreal when i first got here with
ralphie may guys they were giving out
major [ __ ] deals jack you know what
it is to sit with somebody lee that you
and him were broke and now the word on
the street was he had 250 000 for a
network deal and yeah they give you
particles and but they still give you a
75 [ __ ] up front
and you're you're still [ __ ] eating
[ __ ] cheese grills whatever yeah
grilled cheese i'm sorry cheese grill i
got dislikes
all right you know it's just that do you
feel bad how about how about uh the the
story of [ __ ] chicken
all right this kid goes up in montreal
blows the [ __ ] place apart he gets
750k
okay
all right and and his management three
arts
say he had a bunch of more shows and
they're like
[ __ ] get out of here all right and
they flew him back on a private jet to
l.a and said you can't do any spots
because they wanted the deal [ __ ]
made official because they were afraid
the [ __ ] was a hologram which he
was it was the [ __ ] it was crazy
google it all right [ __ ] show up
chicken all right and then the guy like
three or four years later commits
suicide
you know but he had no reason he that
guy was hiring him to do movies i know
so what the stand-up got him to where he
wanted exactly but he stopped
you know that was the last big deal i
think montreal gave out but now he did
black walk down yeah he did
he was great he did a couple [ __ ]
movies with that director he got plenty
of stage time and blackhawk down i don't
know what he was depressed about
i don't know what he was depressed about
what was he depressed now he wasn't the
only one there was a bunch of comics not
that they killed themselves but that
they kind of did they left i still
remember a kid that looked just like
christopher [ __ ] reed
that came from [ __ ] somewhereville
good looking as [ __ ]
six foot one i mean leading man material
buff
not real buff but that model body guy
was getting laughs at the improv the
laugh factory was getting laughs and
then they set up a showcase from one
night
in the main room at the comedy store and
dice decided to bump the guy in front of
him
so dice went up and ripped that room
apart and this poor kid went up there
and died the death of many deaths and i
still remember his management walking
out first
and that kid wasn't a tonight show and
[ __ ] like that i never saw him again
never saw him again there was a kid when
i got here that was hotter than debt
he had done the tonight show and
leno like two weeks apart something
[ __ ] crazy i remember going into the
improv he had five people around him he
was eating them they were toasting them
i remember spotting them going oh my god
that's the guy i was like in all of him
well guess what
i saw that [ __ ] maybe five years ago at
the ymca with a [ __ ] kid
and i went over and i'm like hey man i
remember you what are you doing tonight
because i write on the show
uh i haven't done stand-up in years
there are a bunch of [ __ ] thieves out
there you know just a typical guy that
gave up in his mind
that if he would have stuck with it
today
he would have done something
at least you [ __ ] did something with
it you're already in eight nine years in
what the [ __ ] are you gonna do now
yeah i mean you you've already gotten tv
you've already you've already beaten
99 you can't quit now
you know how many [ __ ] goals i gave
myself when i got here
i used to give myself goes i'm gonna go
back to colorado and try to be a dad bro
how about this one um i'm gonna do a
movie with uh uh robert de niro i'm
gonna do a movie with al pacino i'm
gonna do a movie with adam sandler
that's you you wrote it in my [ __ ] in
my apartment you wrote your goals down i
remember it you called it in [ __ ]
what was it 2 000
in 2000 you called it and within it took
you for what adam sandler what year was
that 2004 2004 four years for adam
sandler okay and then then the other
movie you did with de niro and [ __ ]
pacino what was that when the the ranked
or the the the the old guys
yeah garage match all right and you got
all those [ __ ] goals down i've never
[ __ ] seen anybody do that i've that's
[ __ ] amazing
coco did not have a [ __ ] house he was
sleeping on my [ __ ] floor or when
when [ __ ]
johnny west was being a [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay coco would lay on the goddamn floor
and if johnny west was out banging
chicks or [ __ ] doing gigs coco had
the futon all right he'd blow up my
toilet [ __ ] take three showers a day
i had the futon yeah right
we'd send john to el paso oh and it was
hot we couldn't sleep so we turned on
joey medina's [ __ ] cassette i mean
his cd and [ __ ] we were out before
the like three joke line we're like
we're both out it was the cure for
insomnia god bless you don't remember
being in colorado
in 94 and going home at night there was
a comedy newspaper then
run by the people in san francisco
john fox
and i know in the back they had all the
comedy club listed in states
and there was five pages then at comedy
clubs yeah man i would sit there at
night
it was a magazine called just for just
for last and i would s yellow you know
when you're hungry lee wake up guys
i would highlight
i would highlight all the clubs
i wanted to work at and i would cry and
go i'm never gonna make it this is like
a
and then my buddy todd jordan took me to
walnut creek
to do 10 minutes in front of him and i
hated that two shows oh
i'll never forget i had doubts that
[ __ ] plane ride home that was not for
me boy
i remember that turn of event but
we stuck it out so you're in san jose
this weekend yes sir so starting
thursday yes through friday through
saturday one sunday no sunday just
thursday friday saturday where you go
next week um i'm gonna be back here of
sunday morning i'd love to have you guys
come barbecue we'll go swimming with the
pool the pool is tremendous
all right and it'd be so much fun we're
gonna go have brunch over there and then
i'll have barbecue ready for us
at the house
it'll be a good time
i want to get that baby in the pool with
us so she'll have a blast um but that's
what i want to do on sunday it's the
lord's day let's relax
and then um uh
then the week after that i'm in uh salt
lake city uh
and then back on that sunday and then
uh
i'm going to be in phoenix arizona stand
up live
so that's the
warm up for the tour talking to witch
i love her let me see her
oh me huh oh yeah she's swimming in this
baby
she's a swimmer look at that woman jack
that's the real deal that's the real
deal though i love it she's at that pool
in berdugo
with [ __ ] young adults swimming
kicking i love it people my wife don't
even run out there in that [ __ ] deep
end
she's amazing oh my goodness isn't that
amazing that's [ __ ] crazy look at her
she's barely [ __ ] walking
she's gonna pull on her back
she's on her back look
i i can't see that
holy [ __ ] she don't [ __ ] around that's
what she's been doing since she was here
how old is she now
she's two and a half two and a half
she's my [ __ ] bodyguard i can't shake
it ah
i'm good for you man no i'm i'm i'm so
happy for you
hey as usual my main [ __ ] on it
go to honda.com for the best i mean the
best i read an article the other day
that had on it in there like
towards macronutrients i mean that's how
[ __ ] good i was blown away and i'll
tell you what the staple the mcdaddy
alpha brain 100 guaranteed complete
earth grown nootropics we ain't [ __ ]
around all your brain cells will be
cooking on all cylinders who's better
than you and if it don't cook maybe you
just [ __ ]
send it back to us we don't even want
the [ __ ] thing we'll send you back
your money who does that who gives you
that kind of guarantee but don't stop
there how about the t for the [ __ ] up
your testosterone levels they also have
the the coconut oil for your coffee we
ain't [ __ ] around new mood i mean
listen give it a shot columbus did go to
holland.com right now and press in
church
c-h-u-r-c-h and get ten percent off your
first order or you could
you need [ __ ] uh
uh alpha brain more never [ __ ] sucker
you know what i think i need a few alpha
brains oh second but not least 86.com
what the [ __ ] these are tremendous lee i
hope you have a bunch of these you can
slip me brothers got a bunch of them
there i got some more [ __ ] yeah
the cigars are tremendous this is
tremendous the e-cigs are tremendous the
best thing about them is 1200 guaranteed
[ __ ] pups okay oh my dad my
dad's ordered like 20 of them yes he did
you know why because they're [ __ ] ten
dollars
so five you get five for 50 bucks right
now go to 86.com and press enter joey's
church joey's church and get five for
fifty cinque you get five e6 and get a
cigar you get the zero eight sixteen and
twenty fourths and you get quit off your
[ __ ] cigarette habit number three my
main motherfuckersnailtonlife.com
always there for you
[ __ ] whether you want to dab blow
yourself up whether you want the gumi's
romano whether you want the best vapor
pen in the business that's what they
knew now the other life pete and [ __ ]
dave don't [ __ ] around so do me a favor
go to nailed it life.com
look at that great selection of vapor
pens 100 percent guarantee in fact they
have the vapor pen 20 off right now if
you press in joey diaz boom 20 off it's
50 you get it for [ __ ] 40. you got a
problem you caught dave your [ __ ]
piece is there no ifs ands butts about
it that's why we work them that's why
we're family all right don't forget to
go see ralphie may next week in san jose
and uh the flying jew i love them with
all your heart we'll be back wednesday
afternoon at three o'clock
state black [ __ ] suckers you're going to
play uh
[ __ ] it
[ __ ] yeah man thank you for coming on
ralphie man i love you coco thank you
for having me i'm sorry uh fans if i was
rude you weren't i'm kind of high i
apologize just speaking your mind and
[ __ ] i love you man it's like feel like
i'm talking at the kitchen tell you
about i forget this is your show my
apologies no disrespect no no disrespect
at all he never apologized you know what
i'm saying yeah but you're my brother
how do we [ __ ] short you down
i know
man how hot is that jennifer garner what
is that ben affleck thinking did you see
that [ __ ] oh my god i know
she was really hot yeah she's really hot
she ain't that [ __ ] schwarzenegger guy
with oh jesus i'll tell you that [ __ ]
christ okay that thing was brutal you
see that no oh good lord jesus
looked like coco with a wig on
who
that [ __ ] schwarzenegger made
[ __ ] brutal
got my tits though so you know
on that note
this show is brought to you by
honest.com
church
to get 10 off wait do you see your
website
uh i'm a ralphie mae.com and uh follow
me guys on twitter i'm at ralphie
underscore may it's really me i'm sorry
if you're mad i love you anyways
thanks for having me here you know that
you don't know when we were [ __ ] high
and you're living with me you're like
ravi meg you're gonna be the [ __ ]
deacon of the church of what's happening
now so i feel like it's always good to
come back to the church you know what
i'm saying i ain't mad at you no man i
love you hope that you're back in a
monday night [ __ ] around
we got high and that's it that's how we
do it here no editing just straight up
what are you going to do we love you
[ __ ] leave read the finals all
right go to honor.com and use cover
church to get 10 percent off all the
great optimization you got highway to
hell yes all right let's do it
off all the great optimization products
go to hit e6.com and use codeword joey's
church to get five hit e6 for fifty
dollars
better tasting longer lasting and the
proof is in the vape
and go to another live.com in news cover
joey diaz to get twenty percent off the
premiere paper too highly get blood
no man you're going to be calm don't
break through your nose you'll be fine
i'll spray my nose with afrin and [ __ ]
yeah